وعد اتصل باطلاق ميزه القياده الذاتيه
الكامله في عام 2018 لكنها ظهرت اخيرا فقط
في تموز 2021 لعدد صغير بنفس سائقين
الخبراء والحذرين النظام الجديد المقدم من
تسلا هو امتدال لمزه السائق الالي لمساعده
مستخدمي سيارات تسلاح حيث تتوسع بوظائف
اليه مثل التوجيه الالي في المدن ووقوف
السيارات الاوتوماتيكي واستدعاء المركبات
الذكيه والتعرف على اشارات المرور وعلامات
التوقف
التكنولوجيا الحاليه تتطلب من السائقين
بقاء يدهم على عجله القياده للسيطره على
السياره في اي لحظه فكل 45 ثانيه يخبرك
البرنامج ان تشد عجله القياده لتتاكد من
انك منتبه وفي حال شعر السياره انك غير
منتبه فانها توقف القياده الذاتيه واذا
اوقفت القياده ذاتيه خمس مرات فانها تطردك
من البرنامج سيارات القياده ذاتيه الكامله
لتسلا هي بلا شكوى واحده من اكثر انظمه
القاده شبه المستقله تقدما في العالم
لكنها لا تزعل بحاجه الى الكثير من العمل
بحسب الخبراء